What you're looking at is a clam's foot.
That's right, clams have a foot.
And some species can
extend it several inches.
But as it turns out, a foot is just one
of the many bizarre features
you'll find inside a clam.
Like oysters and mussels,
clams are bivalves,
a kind of mollusk that's
encased in a shell
made of two valves, or hinging parts.
And that shell comes
in all different sizes.
There are small clams, like these,
which are often used for cooking.
And then there are giant clams,
which can grow more than a meter long
and weigh as much as 250 kilograms.
But no matter their size, clams have
some truly bizarre stuff going on inside.
And to get a closer
look, we went clamming.
Benji Jones: Oh, God. [laughing]
Narrator: That's marine
biologist Soren Dahl,
who took us clamming on Long Island.
At first, we didn't have much luck.
Benji: I got one, but
it looks like it's dead.
Soren Dahl: Old shell.
Benji: Oh, I got a crab.
Narrator: Then we
stumbled upon what's known
as a honey hole.
It's basically a clammer's
code word for jackpot.
Benji: Hey! I got two! [laughing]
Soren: All right!
Narrator: And in the end, we found about
a dozen hard clams.
Benji: This right here
is my recently collected,
my recently collected clams,
and I have a lot of them.
Narrator: Now, to see what's inside,
you can't exactly pry one
open with your bare hands.
And that's thanks to these two muscles.
They run from the inside
of one shell to the other,
and when clams sense a threat
or find themselves out
of water, they contract,
causing the clam to, you know,
[snapping]
clam up.
So, to get one open,
you need to cut through those muscles.
Soren: Now, you have your,
this is your hard-shell clam.
Benji: Both of, so those
two muscles together
create a muscle that
goes from here to here?
Soren: Yep, this goes from
this side to that side.
Narrator: And what
about that strange foot?
Soren: This is the foot, right here.
Narrator: So, it might not
be as impressive as this,
but that's just because
here the foot is retracted.
Soren: And they'll extend
this out of the clam,
and they can push
themselves along the bottom
and use it to dig a hole
to help bring themselves
into, like, a burrow.
Narrator: And some clams are particularly
dexterous with their foot.
The razor clam, for example,
can bury itself 70
centimeters underground.
It uses rapid movements of its foot
to fluidize the ground around it,
essentially turning it into quicksand.
But if you think clam feet are bizarre,
check out this thing: the siphon.
Siphons are essentially
two connected straws
that clams stick out of their shells.
One pulls in water,
which contains food particles and oxygen,
and the other expels waste.
And none is more impressive
than the one belonging
to the geoduck clam.
It's so big the clam can't
even close its shell.
While siphons allow
clams to eat and breathe,
some clams have another,
more advanced tactic
for getting nutrients.
Instead of just sucking
food out of the water,
giant clams farm it themselves.
Like coral, they have a
symbiotic relationship
with microalgae.
The clams provide algae
with a place to live
and photosynthesize, and in exchange,
algae gives the clam
byproducts of photosynthesis,
such as sugars, which
enables the giant clams
to grow, you know, giant.
Now, on rare occasions,
there's something else you
might find inside a clam:
a pearl.
That's right, oysters aren't
the only pearl producers out there.
Clams, too, will form
these shimmering clumps
to trap irritants that enter their shells.
In fact, a fisherman once found
a 34-kilogram pearl
inside a giant clam.
So, yeah, clams aren't just fascinating;
they might also be precious.
Plus, they actually play an important role
in their environment.
By sucking up particles to eat,
they function like natural water filters,
making marshes, lakes, and
other habitats more livable.
And, on top of that,
they're delicious to eat.
Not to mention, really fun to collect.